this morning we're introducing a special
four-part series called the world of
motion a team of CBS news correspondents
traveled around the world to Japan
Greece southern Africa and Scotland to
discover how and why people are on the
move
CBS this morning Saturday co-anchor
Michelle Miller is here with the results
of a friendly competition between the
u.s. and Japan focusing on train travel
Michelle good morning good morning the
daily commute can be a chore no matter
where you live but some definitely have
it better than others my colleague rainy
Inocencio rode the rails in Japan while
I boarded trains right here to see how
American ingenuity stacks up to Japanese
efficiency rush hour in New York City is
a daily challenge for its commuters who
like most Americans tend to rely on
their cars as their main source of
transportation that despite the city
having the nation's largest subway
system spanning more than six hundred
sixty-five miles and carrying over 5.4
million
every day
crowds they are a thing here in Tokyo to
Michelle this city has a population of
14 million people and about half of them
take to the rails every day and here's
something that might be surprising to
American people here politely line up
for trains that arrive on time nearly
every time for station New York's busy
people here might be surprised to know
there's a schedule at all as for lining
up but get about it in Tokyo stations
aren't just places to catch a train
there are also destinations to get a
gourmet meal like here in ramen row the
dining choices here aren't as good but
you're never too far away from a slice
of pizza
rare to see a rodent here but it
definitely is a rat race
the Guinness Book of World Records says
Tokyo's Shinjuku Station is the busiest
in the world
but look how clean it is sure these
trains and stations could use a bit more
attention but despite all of that and
the delays this subway runs 24 hours a
day
subway service in Tokyo ends at around
midnight and restarts at around 5 a.m.
that let's cruise 10 to station
maintenance no matter what time you ride
or half by the trip they are in New York
this thing prices here vary depending on
how far you go
but it's time not cost that matters most
to rail passengers in Japan the bullet
train or the Shinkansen is still the
world's most reliable form of public
transportation we're boarding in Tokyo
for a trip to Kyoto 319 miles away and
we'll ride and tracks high-speed rail he
is fellas from New York to Washington DC
which is about 225 miles that gives us a
nearly 100 mile headstart Michelle you
did hear that bit about this being the
world's most reliable high-speed train
service right it's also super fast with
a top speed of 177 miles per hour on
this line that is pretty fast ramming
the Acela only averages about 82 miles
per hour are the reason for that it
shares its tracks with both its local
lines and freight trains too well that
was pleasant here we are in Kyoto
Michelle right on time in exact two
hours and 18 minutes
congratulations Raymond if we stay on
schedule which Amtrak dozen 20% of the
time we should get to DC in about Oh 40
minutes
although Amtrak is promising some
upgrades it should shave 15 minutes off
of the commute by the Year 2021 15 whole
minutes and that's something to look
forward to Michelle in the meantime with
the extra time we've got now we're gonna
take a visit to Japan's old imperial
capital wish you were here
yeah me too rainy me too nice come on up
a recap Raimi Rodo train about a hundred
miles further and completed that trip
roughly 40 minutes sooner than I did so
when it comes to travelling by train
Americans are far behind our friends in
Japan but the Shinkansen may be making
its way to the United States there is a
private company in Texas that hopes to
start next year between Dallas and
Houston shaving that or trimming that
back canoe down to 90 they get here fast
enough yeah I gotta hand it to Ramey he
look very suave I know very suave and
de-boner
Wow I really believe this is the will of
the nation
you know infrastructure building is so
important here and I know some 20 years
ago the mayor's really got behind a move
to bring high-speed rail service here
along with the governors and the federal
government what happened 9/11 all the
money that was going toward that went to
Homeland Security so gotta dig deep
there were a lot of great moments
between the two of you but one in
particular when he said they're waiting
politely to board the train yes that was
the one people practice I was a quiet
moment York subway thank you very much